if the person's doing the vision board
and they're saying when i get my new car
i get my new house i get my new
relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great
now that well then they're back to the
program waiting for it to happen
for them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's there's no
effect of drawing the experience to you
with that way
so the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process
and you feel grateful you feel a love
for life you feel a joy for existence
you feel a passion
uh
to
for the moment
uh
you will not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened
it's the moment that we start feeling
those self-limiting emotions that we
feel separation and then we start
looking for it again well then if you're
waiting you're not creating you're
you're in separation again so then yeah
so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so then if you wake
up in the morning and you
come come back to your senses with a
clean slate and you say i don't feel
anything you say well let me start
thinking about all the problems in my
life well all those problems are
connected to different people or
different objects of things at different
times and places the moment you remember
your problems a memory is a record of
the past you're thinking in the past
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them so all of a
sudden you start feeling unhappy you
start feeling bitter you start feeling
frustrated so now your body's in the
past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion
and the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass
because that feeling is going to drive
your behaviors it's going to drive more
of those thoughts and when you feel that
feeling and it's visceral
no person
no thing no experience will stand in the
way between you and that vision and and
you will be initiated
in by the universe into wealth you will
be initiated into health you'll be
initiated into freedom those people
all those people that have healed
themselves of all those different health
conditions
they are so humble
and so happy and they feel so great that
they would never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've they've left that program behind
a long time ago they actually don't care
how you think of them they they actually
are so happy with themselves
that they are no longer dependent on
anything outside of that now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
need motivation watch top 10 we believe
nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best dr joe
dispenza and my take on his top 10 rules
for success enjoy
rule number two refuse to be a victim
one of the things about the global
pandemic that i said to my staff and to
my family the moment i heard how the
circumstances in the world changed
i just said i refuse to be a victim
to these circumstances so a victim
consciousness is when
we allow something in our outer
environment to control the way we feel
and think so if i say to you jay why are
you so upset today and you said oh it's
because of this person or circumstance
what you're really saying is
something in my outer environment some
person or some condition is controlling
the way i think and feel and that's not
the truth that's just a response right
so anything that controls our thoughts
and feelings causes us to be victim to
those things and the stronger the
emotion we feel to some circumstance in
our life the more we pay attention to it
and where we place our attention is
where we place our energy so
we're giving our life force we're giving
our power away to that circumstance and
so i just made up my mind that uh it was
a great opportunity to get into the
cocoon rule number three practice inner
work we've done an experiment just 10
minutes a day
three times a day with 120 people
trading resentment frustration fear for
gratitude appreciation and
thankfulness measuring their immune
response
the the chemical immunoglobulin a your
primary defense against bacteria and
viruses the best flu shot you'll ever
get lives innately within you turns out
when you're frustrated when you're
impatient when you're fearful
the immune system dials down because
you're an emergency it's not it's all
your energy is going for some threat in
your outer world there's no energy in
your inner world for growth and repair
but how do you turn that around so then
as people begin to open their heart
can that chemical begin
to to elevate
four days
50
change in the 120 people their their iga
levels went up 50 in four days that's
your body's immune system is now up
regulating genes that are making
proteins and immunoglobulins and
antibodies that you don't need a flu
shot in other words your inner state is
greater than your outer world so then
just by doing that we now know that your
immune system is going to get stronger
by the same means
take 120 people or 50 people and measure
7500 gene regulations
in four days
two genes that suppress cancer growth
and tumors are activated and upregulated
the genes that stimulate stem cells to
go to damaged tissues and repair them up
regulate them the gene for oxidative
balance is upregulated anti-cancer
anti-aging anti-heart disease
anti-stroke anti-neurodegenerative
anti-inflammatory antimicrobial just
your body's naturally doing this
the gene for neurogenesis the growth of
new neurons in response to novel
experiences and learning this is four
days the gene switches on
the gene for more balance in the
pituitary and the pancreas the gene for
the microtubules of the cells the
little the little fibers that respond to
energy and frequency so in four days we
now know that you can change your
genetic destiny
if you just practice the inner work rule
number four create a clear vision if you
think about this your senses plug you
into your external environment
everything you're seeing or smelling or
tasting or feeling or hearing all of
your five senses are affecting your
brain
so if you're waking up in the morning
and you're going through the same
routine behaviors as you did the day
before
and you're not in the process of being
defined by a vision of the future
then you're for the most part left with
the old hardware in your brain from the
past as a matter of fact your brain is
organized to reflect everything you know
from the past
so as people wake up and they begin to
pay attention to their body they start
to look around in their environment they
start to do typical things
it's the external environment that's
turning on different circuits in their
brain causing them to think equal to
their environment
and if you have the idea that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny as long as you're thinking equal
to your environment you keep creating
the same reality over and over again so
to change is to think greater than your
environment to think greater than the
circumstances in your world to think
greater than the conditions in your life
and i think every great person in
history understood this they were
defined by a vision that was much bigger
than that also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief i've
designed a special free training to help
you do it the science says it can take
up to 254 days of consecutive action to
build a new habit and i want that for
you i want you to build the habit of
self belief so what i'm going to do is
email you every day for 254 days a link
to an unlisted video that will shift
your belief forward to get on it for
free the link to join is in the
description below you were up and
dressed and ready to go before your
parents were up you know why because you
knew something unexpected was going to
happen that's how we should live our
lives waking up with the understanding
to expect the unexpected if you're going
to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about today
what creates marketing is when you don't
just market but you add value to people
rule number five filter information i
think one of the challenges i think many
people have is really the discernment of
information
it's really difficult to know what's the
truth anymore just because information
is so accessible and i used to say that
in an age of information ignorance is a
choice and and now we have to confront a
whole another level and that is the
information that we're getting uh is it
is it actually supporting us or is it
something that really is an incentive to
to cause us to make choices so um for me
i think the biggest challenge has been
just really an awakening to
what kind of information i want to
expose myself to and i think it's now
more than ever a challenge for a lot of
people in the world rule number six
meditate we have research to show that
60 days of meditation
five days a week
will lengthen your life the telomeres
the little shoestrings on the end of
your dna get longer that means your
biological age is changing
so we we have the evidence now
to show people what's possible we have
brain scans that that are so outside of
normal that when neuroscientists see
them they're blown away because the
amount of energy that's in the brain
during this transcendental moment is uh
hundreds of times outside of normal wow
i mean you can't make your brain do that
something is happening to you and that
person's
having a transcendental moment and we
now know that we can predict it and we
now that know that we can induce it so
then there's the evidence there
then you take
our community and you see people with
stage four cancer with parkinson's
disease with myasthenia gravis with
with lupus with ms with
brain injuries
with rare genetic disorders with vertigo
tinnitus
kidney failure all kinds of health
conditions
come to a week-long event
and then at the end of that event
they make significant strides in getting
beyond the emotions of the past now
think about this
the science says that the environment
signals the gene that's epigenetics
the end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion so as long as
you're living by the same emotion every
single day you're signaling the same
gene in the same way and if that gene is
related to a survival emotion a stress
hormone then you're down regulating the
gene and you're creating disease so when
the person trades that emotion and
really breaks free from the chains of
their past
and now they're feeling an elevated
emotion
well now they're dialing down the gene
for ms and they're up regulating the
gene for health and balance and so the
person will you'll say to them where's
the disease well i'm not the same person
i'm not and and the side effect
of that is a transformation in healing
so
the funny thing about it is the person
who has the healing is not talking about
the healing
whether it's blind people seeing deaf
people hearing hearing we have crazy
evidence now
what they're talking about is how
amazing they feel
because
they're refreshed they're they're they
got a new lease on life and so now we
have evidence
in our research
and that silence is the critic to show
that what's possible for people rule
number seven tame the body if you're
sitting in a meditation and your body's
throwing the kitchen sink at you and
saying ed you're a loser you're never
gonna change this is too hard why don't
you quit and you're aware that that's
your body doing that and you say to your
body
we're going to sit here
and we're going to sit in this fire and
i'm going to keep applying the formula
and my your brain starts running to all
the emails you have to do and you become
aware of that and return back to the
present moment and you tell the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind now your will is getting greater
than that program and there's a
liberation of energy and every time you
do that that's a victory
and you teach every time you do that
that's a victory when your mind tells
the body i'm in charge when you say
you're when you you just want to get up
and you want to quit and you got no no
that's my body bring it back okay and
now you're now you're taming the animal
the body is the animal and you're like a
dog you sit
and if you keep doing this keep doing
this you're climbing on top and the body
finally acquiesces it finally says i'm
not going anywhere and then boom there's
this liberation of energy what's the
side effect
joy a person's heart just automatically
opens up and and every time they do that
those victories add up there's no such
thing as a bad meditation there's only
overcoming yourself and when you sit in
the fire
and you work with that people say to me
why do you meditate every morning i say
because if i can overcome myself in the
morning the rest of my day is easy it's
easy true because because that's what
it's about you master yourself you
master your life yes and so then all the
chatter in your head that you listen to
all day long that is called the default
mode network in the brain my research
shows
that shuts off not just shuts off during
the meditation it stays shut off for the
rest of the day so the critic in your
head that's telling you this will never
happen you don't have enough time all
right that there's no voice there so you
just have a clear
flow of where you're going and you trust
yourself more rule number eight make it
about the effort look i mean we are
we're in a convenience-based society i
mean if you if you lose your internet
connection or your cell phone doesn't do
it it's supposed to people get angry
like that's 20 seconds right so here you
are creating something out of nothing
and you don't have the patience well
that has to come out because
a very very masterful person
who is abundant
had to own
impatience so then never make it be
about the end result make it be about
effort
every day you're overcoming every day
you're out of the bleachers and you're
on the field and you're giving it your
all and you're practicing keeping your
energy up greater than your habits in
your body or the emotional conditioning
of your body greater than any
circumstance in your environment and
sustaining it for an extended period of
time and all of a sudden
when you're connected to the energy of
your future
and you know what that feels like yeah
you will know the moment you return back
to the energy of your past and if you
tell me it's because of your boss your
co-worker your ex i'm going to say ah
you're back to the unconscious program
that you're the victim of your life
right so then so then it takes some
unlearning and the unlearning process is
the most important process because once
you do that you're clearing out room for
the next creation to be easier and the
next one to be easier because you're
starting to understand the formula a
little better and you start saying i'm
not going to take that personally or i'm
not going to react or i'm not going to
go back to that person again i'm just
going to self-regulate again yeah you
only need a few experiences to know that
this is the truth and then you start
making start managing your attention you
manage your energy a lot better and i
think that i i always say i don't care
that you fall off the horse i just care
when you get back on right because some
people fall off and then they have to go
into guilt and analysis and and they
take weeks and well you could have just
said i fell off let me just get back on
and keep going here rule number nine
control your thoughts
every time we have a thought we make a
chemical and and if you have
an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have
a self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
it turns out that
the emotions that are created from the
thoughts are the signaling mechanisms of
the body thoughts of the language of the
brain and feelings are the language of
the body and how we think and how we
feel
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones
based in survival those are the thoughts
that begin to push the genetic buttons
that create disease in other words
a person wakes up in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people certain objects uh
certain things at certain times and
places so if you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny the moment you think about your
problems you're thinking in the past
right
now every one of those problems
has an emotion associated with them
because we've experienced them so the
moment you remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear
so the moment we feel those emotions it
takes a thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion
a stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition so if the environment signals
the gene and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is
uh the brain checks in with the body and
says yeah you're feeling pretty
miserable you're suffering and we tend
to generate more thoughts
equal to the feeling that we have
and so then we get caught in this loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
then we're thinking in the past and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is breakthrough
self-limiting beliefs i'm starting to
realize how conditioned we are into
believing how limited we are
and as you start peeling those layers
away and you break through those beliefs
those self-limiting thoughts and
emotions
on the other side of that is where the
miraculous happens so you got to be
willing to be in that place of
discomfort long enough to reorganize
order and begin to create more coherence
and then all of a sudden you get this
recalibration that goes on in the brain
and body and then the extent of that is
that the ultimate thing is you start to
see feedback in your life those
synchronicities those coincidences those
opportunities you're scratching your
head going
everything is falling into place yeah
i'm in the right place at the right time
i think about just comes to me because
your energy is synchronized it's
look i mean
when you have coherence in the brain and
heart you have a laser of energy and it
could read information much better
you're living in stress and your brain
is shifting its attention from one
person to another problem to another
thing to another
place to go
each one of those things there's an
assignment of neurological networks in
the brain so the arousal of the stress
hormones drives the brain into this high
frequency and you're trying to control
and predict everything in your life and
those your brain circuits are firing
like a like a lightning storm in the
clouds when your brain's incoherent
you're incoherent and and you can't you
don't have a signal
you don't have a wi-fi signal i'm not
connected to the field how could you how
could you connect to energy and
information if your signal hasn't become
orderly so that when people synchronize
their energy into coherence they can
synchronize to a possibility in the
future and the synchronicities
that are feedback from the environment
are just a reflection of your energy
and that's the universe saying
follow the breadcrumbs do it again
follow it again do it again and now all
of a sudden the person's not waking in
the morning like oh
i gotta meditate now to create my future
they're kind of going like i'm getting
out of bed because i don't want the
magic to end right they want to they
want to sustain that state so that
the old
reality that they've lived in begins to
transform into something new and because
there's no longer a vibrational match
with everyone and everything in their
past present reality there's a
vibrational match to their future and
now their future is starting to give
them signals now i've got some special
bonus clips that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week when you just watch a
video and you get motivated the sign
says you have a 35 chance of actually
following through that's not good enough
believe nation we need to take some
action but when you watch a video you
get motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
percent to 91 chance of you following
through and when you publicly commit to
other people like leaving a comment down
in this video your number jumps to 95
percent change of you actually following
through on the plan you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week leave it
down in the comments below so i can
celebrate you when you start practicing
creating that brain and heart coherence
you can believe in a future that you
can't see or experience with your senses
yet but you've thought about enough
times in your mind that it's actually
there's physical evidence in your brain
to look like it's already happening and
you can begin to understand you can
select a new potential in the quantum
field and every day emotionally embrace
that future reality to such a degree
that your body begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and you're signaling new
genes and new ways to change your body
to look like it's already happened now
think about this
if there's physical evidence by thought
alone
in your brain and body to look like your
wealth or your future has already
happened
it's already happened i'm very happy and
you're already it so it's not about your
wealth it's not about your health it's
not about your freedom it's who you
become so then as you overcome overcome
overcome overcome you become someone
else and so most people don't understand
that
that the truth is is that every time you
overcome yourself a little bit more the
side effect is that you love yourself a
little bit more we have a huge frontal
lobe and it's 40 of our entire brain
and most people
when they have a thought they just think
that that's the truth and i think one of
my greatest
realizations in my own journey was
just because you have a thought doesn't
necessarily mean it's true
so if you think 60 to 70 000 thoughts in
one day and we do and 90 of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before and you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny your life's not going to change
very much because the same thought leads
to the same choice the same choice leads
to the same behavior the same behavior
creates the same experience and the same
experience produces the same emotion
and so then
the act of becoming conscious of this
process to
to begin to become more aware
of how you think how you act and how you
feel it's called metacognition and so
then
why is that important because the more
conscious
you become of those unconscious states
of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought
is not going to slip by your awareness
unchecked
because you're
it means to know thyself the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so as you become familiar with the
thoughts the behaviors and the emotions
of the old self you're retiring that old
self as you fire and wire new thoughts
and condition the body into a new
emotional state if you do that enough
times it'll begin to become familiar to
you so
it's so important
just like a garden if you're planting a
garden you've got to get rid of the
weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out the
rocks that sift to the top that are like
our emotional blocks they have to be
removed that soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to we have to
make room to plant a new garden so
primarily we learn the most about
ourselves and others when we're
uncomfortable because the moment you
move into that uncomfortable state
normally a program jumps in when that
program jumps in it's because the person
doesn't want to be in the present moment
and engage it consciously
so when you teach people how to do that
with a meditative process it turns out
that when they're in their life
they're less likely to emotionally react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and that
is what starts the process of change and
so we have to unlearn before we relearn
we have to break the habit of the old
self before we reinvent the new south we
have to prune synaptic connections and
sprout new connections we have to
un-fire and unwire and re-fire and
rewire we have to un-memorize emotions
that are stored in the body then
recondition the body to a new mind into
a new motion like deprogram and
reprogram that's the act and it's a
two-step process overcoming the old self
allows us to become somebody else and
there is that period of transition yeah
i call it the void where there's just
not a lot happening
and you just got to be able to keep
going and continuously get to the end of
your belief where most people stop i
just had a fabulous conversation with
someone uh this weekend
broke through to the other side
and now there's so much magic happening
around this person
but she's worthy now
to receive it and that's that
that is the key because the universe
only gives us what we think we're worthy
of receiving so we gotta become
initiated into this and understand it
thousands of years of programming that
says that we have to change things
matter to matter you know in
three-dimensional reality and it will
take time but
to begin to connect to that resource
called the quantum field and create from
the field instead of from matter
there's a lot of unlearning that has to
go on the stronger the emotion you feel
from some event in your life be it a
betrayal or a trauma or whatever yes the
more altered you feel inside of you the
more you pay attention to the cause
outside of you so the brain takes a
snapshot
it freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory
so we create long-term memories from
strong emotional events okay so is that
true i just want to understand the maybe
the larger the event in terms of its
emotion to you the stronger of a hold it
has over you yeah well the more it's
embossed in your biology so some certain
people have a strong experience in their
life
and it catches all of the brain's
attention so now they think
neurologically within the circuits of
the past experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event
and you keep that refractory period of
chemicals going on for extended periods
of time so that the event produces a
chemical change and the body needs to
return back to homeostasis or balance
but if it can't then the elongation of
that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say ed what's
wrong with you i'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and i'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry i don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago i'm
having one long emotional reaction i'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves
by living in the past and so then you
say to them well tell me the story now
the latest research on memory says that
50
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have wow just to reaffirm that they
can't change right wow
so then what's the significance of this
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy period yes so then
the stronger the emotion that you have
to some problem or condition or person
in your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
away
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now
this is the significance when a person
really decides to be defined by a vision
of the future instead of the memory of
the past the hardest part about it is
all of a sudden becoming conscious and
not making the same unconscious choice
so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lowered the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back i think
this is a time in history where it's not
enough to know there's a time in history
to know how
and
if you rewind the tape 10 years ago you
know information was the thing that
stimulated thought stimulated new ideas
and and as we learn new things we make
new connections in our brains so
as we begin to add new stitches into
that three-dimensional tapestry in our
mind
we're beginning to cause our mind to
function in new ways but the key then
is to apply it to personalize it to do
something with it in in ten years ago
when i went got in front of an audience
and talked about the application
nobody wanted to step outside that
philosophical theoretical intellectual
realm right because when doing something
means you're gonna have to change
something about yourself yeah you're
gonna get uncomfortable right
and um
i think we're in an age of information
and in an age of information ignorance
is a choice and because of technology we
have access to so much content
and information creates awareness and
awareness is consciousness and you can't
have consciousness without energy there
they work together so there's an
energetic change i think that's taking
place in the world right now where
people are so informed
that old models old paradigms are
beginning to break down whether it's the
medical model or the religious model the
educational model journalism uh
the economy you know
politics it's all beginning to uh
come to the surface because something
else has to come out and and i think
that one of the things that people are
realizing is that you don't have to be a
buddhist monk to do this or a nun with
40 years of devotion you just got to
understand the formula and just like any
skill or anything you learn
you got to go from thinking to doing to
being you got to take knowledge you
create the experience and if you keep
doing it over and over again you start
getting a skill or you start getting
wise about how to do it and you you know
that you know how to do it three types
of stress physical chemical and
emotional physical stress trauma
accidents injuries false
chemical stress toxins pollutants heavy
metals blood sugar levels viruses
bacterias mold and then there's
emotional stress which has everything to
do with raising kids and and second
mortgages and single parenting and time
and
and all of those different elements
knock the brain and body out of balance
and the emotional component has always
been the challenging one for most people
because
you could be in a constant state of fear
if we teach a person then how to trade
that frustration or that hatred for an
elevated emotion and they'll say yeah
but you know it was my ex's fault or i
got betrayed by my partner in business
yeah yeah yeah we know that okay so
let's take your partner in business or
take your ex let's duct tape them put
them in a can and shoot them to the moon
now what are you going to do sooner or
later you got to reckon with yourself
and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're gonna practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well i can't feel
gratitude and i say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's gonna take a little time to cause
that heart of you to bloom or your heart
of yours to bloom once they're able to
feel even the smallest measure of
gratitude where they start feeling
appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something
when you're receiving something
when something has happened to you
or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific destiny and you've got to
maintain that modified state of mind and
body your entire day
independent of the conditions in your
outer environment
independent of your body's cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can
get ready because something weird or
unusual some synchronicity some
coincidence some opportunity is going to
land in your lap and you didn't have to
go and get it yes it came to you now
you're the vortex of creation so if you
say to me well i was feeling gratitude
but then there was traffic or my
co-worker sent me a nasty email then i
would say oh my god
you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think you're
back to the unconscious program that
you're the victim to your life you got
it but when you start producing those
outcomes in your life you're going to
pay attention to what you did inside of
you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life and
less of the victim of your life if
you're sitting down and you start
thinking about
some future worst-case scenario that
you're conjuring up in your mind
and you begin to feel the emotion of
that event
your body doesn't know the difference
between the event that's taking place in
your world our world and what you're
creating by emotion or thought alone
so most people then
they're they're constantly reaffirming
their emotional states so when it comes
time
to give up that emotion
they can say i really want to do it but
really the body is stronger than the
mind because it's been conditioned that
way so
the servant now has become the master
and the person all of a sudden once they
step into that unknown they'd rather
feel guilt in suffering because at least
they can predict it being the unknown
is a scary place for most people because
the unknown is uncertain people say to
me well i can't predict my future
i'm in the unknown and i always say the
best way to predict your future is to
create it not from the known but from
the unknown what thoughts do you want to
fire and wire in your brain
what behaviors do you want to
demonstrate in one day the act of
rehearsing them mentally closing your
eyes and rehearsing the action
they're rehearsing the reaction of what
you want or
the action of what you want by closing
your eyes and mentally rehearsing some
action
if you're truly present the brain does
not know the difference between what
you're imaging and what you're
experiencing in 3d world
so then you begin to install the
neurological hardware in your brain to
look like the event has already occurred
now your brain is no longer a record of
the past now it's a map to the future
and if you keep doing it priming it that
way
the hardware becomes a software program
and who knows you just may start acting
like a happy person i think
that we define reality with our senses
and i think that is one of the biggest
delusions so the fundamental question is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet but you've thought about
enough times in your mind
that your brain is literally changed to
look like the event has already occurred
now the latest research in plasticity
says that's absolutely possible and can
you select a new possibility in the
quantum field
and begin to emotionally embrace that
future every single day to such a degree
that your body as the unconscious mind
the objective mind does not know the
difference between the experience in
your life that's creating the emotion
and the emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone to the degree that you
begin to signal new genes and new ways
to change your body to look like the
experience has already happened now yes
the latest research in epigenetics says
it's absolutely possible now think about
this every day
installing the circuitry every day
conditioning the body into the emotion
of the future
that your body begins to change to look
like it's already happened now this is
where it gets fun
because now you no longer have to go
anywhere to get it
now it begins to come to you you become
the vortex or the magnet to your destiny
so then people who come out of their
meditation and they say well i just
focused on my wealth why isn't it there
well you're not that good if you're
asking why isn't it there you're back to
the old person again
stay in that state for an extended
period of time
as
an experiment as the scientist in your
life to keep your energy connected to
the to the dream of your future
and then
see what kind of effects begin to take
place without moving into impatience
without moving into frustration without
starting to analyze why it hasn't
happened or when that is the trap of
defining reality with your senses so you
have the thought of your future and you
don't see it then you experience
separation
but people who are practicing this work
they have the thought of the future and
they feel the emotion of their future
they're still connected to it right so
that takes practice and it's just
learning like hitting a golf ball
hitting a tennis ball dancing the salsa
you know crocheting whatever it is you
gotta you gotta start out staying real
conscious and learning then you get good
at it and gets to be instrumental it
gets to be fun and that's that's what i
want for everybody that the act of
creation
should be a blissful
ecstatic loose
uh free process and um
and so
i love the idea of people taking time
out of their lives
uh to prove to themselves that if
they're defined by the vision of the
future
then they're not living by the memories
of the past and that's where the unknown
exists so many people
the unknown is a scary place
so they don't see that future
because they're used to seeing that
future with evidence with their senses
and you have to be able to get beyond
that and stay in the unknown
stay in that discomfort and then in that
moment to be begin to self-regulate like
oh i'm starting to feel a little anxiety
ooh i'm starting to feel a little
frustration
that's the defining moment where your
body's going back to the past because
emotions are a record of the past
or you go into routine again so you
catch yourself
it's a victory
and if you keep catching yourself those
victories add up and it's not so much
about your wealth or your health or your
freedom or your new relationship
it's actually about who you become
i'm not the type of guy who sits in my
house meditating 24 hours a day and
expect things to come to me i'm a
pragmatist
i'm a practical person i'm going to take
value and information i'm going to apply
it and see if i can gain more value from
it so
the message is not to sit and meditate
and just receive universal love and do
nothing else
because
my message is to not disengage in life
but to fully engage in life that's my
message i think
you know if we everything starts with a
thought i mean everything that you do in
your life you you have to have a thought
before you initiate an action right so
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
like any great leader in history
understands that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so give you an example
most people wake up in the morning
and your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact of everything you've
learned and experienced to this moment
right it's a it's a memory bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those problems are
connected to certain people and things
at certain times and places and the
moment they start start turning on those
circuits those memories are actually
causing them to think in the past
every single one of those memories has
an emotion associated with them and
emotions are the end product of past
experiences
so then the moment they recall the event
or the they recall some problem in their
life they start feeling unhappy they
start feeling discouraged they start
feeling anxious now thoughts of the
language of the brain and feelings of
the language of the body and how you
think and how you feel creates your
state of being so we could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past well if you live in the familiar
past then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future so what
happens for most people is they get
stuck in their biology so think about
this
your body is your unconscious mind it
doesn't know the difference between an
experience in your life that creates an
emotion
and an emotion that you can create by
thought alone so if you're living by the
same emotion every single day and those
emotions are influencing your thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel or feelings have become the means
of thinking you're thinking in the past
your lens of the future is going to be
colored by the past so you can't see
possibilities so most people like to
wait for crisis or disease or diagnosis
before they wake up enough to see well
the challenge is is that biology tends
to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts be begin to fire
certain circuits in your brain the nerve
cells that fire together wire together
so all of a sudden you start getting
hardwired and those are the thoughts
that you can think the easiest at the
same time those thoughts produce
chemicals called emotions and the next
thing you know your body gets accustomed
to living by the same emotions and it
could be guilt it could be unhappiness
it could be pain but at least it's
familiar to you at least you can predict
it so some people would rather cling to
the familiar than take a chance and
possibilities so
for most people then they say well
i don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so the first step to change
is starting to think about what you've
been thinking about and change it and
and then when you begin to observe those
thoughts you're no longer the program
you're the consciousness observing just
simply by being an observer of your
thoughts right so so though so most
people though when they when you do that
when you decide to really take a look
it's like lighting a match in a dark
place
so you feel uncomfortable so it's easier
to turn on your tv it's easier to
play with your cell phone to distract
yourself from those feelings well
when you understand that change really
requires becoming uncomfortable to a
certain degree and that's normal that
you're leaving the known and you're
stepping into the unknown
then it begs the question what thoughts
do you want to fire and wire in your
brain because your attention on those
thoughts begins to reorganize circuitry
re-mold the brain you have to really
begin to
mentally rehearse
like so you ask yourself at the end of
your day i do this every day how'd i do
how'd i do today bro how'd you do did
you do good where'd you fall from grace
what what what was it
that caused you to go unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student
of life
you'll begin to contemplate well it was
that person that said that thing then i
reacted or this i got this email or
things didn't go my way and i started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens
how could i evolve my experience now you
may have to search for some answers
of the best model to build or you may
actually have a long contemplation and
start to go god the next time that
happens i think i'm going to do this or
i'm going to do that or i'm going to
plan my behaviors
and the act of closing your eyes
and rehearsing what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the future and if you keep
installing that hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important
than the news right it's more important
than answering any email or any text
it's more important than talking about
your past or some dinner
if you can begin to just think about how
you're going to do it differently
that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time that means you got to
shut your cell phone off you got to
close your door you got to take a break
from everything out there and begin to
practice and so
by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear
and now we've given people the tools to
be able to self-regulate to create brain
and heart coherence and so you see
people say excuse me one minute i just
need a minute
it takes some breaths they get back in
they connect to the energy of their
future this is incidental
compared to where they're going so they
don't
fall from grace they don't allow their
energy to drop and so
yeah in the beginning
it takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness
to stay conscious and not go unconscious
but if you're persistent and you're
determined then you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say
i am not going to give my power away to
that person or that circumstance when i
can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then
won't excuse themselves and say on a
hard day yesterday at a fight with my
co-worker or my ex or and i don't feel
like doing the work well
that's the time to get back on the horse
yeah because because
it's the it's all of those times that we
self-correct
those are the most valuable moments thus
people who've had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they
we say got lit up they connected and
their brain goes into very very high
coherent states and super gamma patterns
that are way outside of normal and they
have a transcendental download or
connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past
because it got them to that moment
that's the moment the past no longer
exists now by the same means
they look back at their past
and they see all those tough moments
where they overcame themselves and they
fall in love with that person they don't
look at the good meditations or the
things that went well they look they
know that it was those moments that got
them to this moment and i i think then
that's when they begin to understand
that that all of the hard work
all the effort
in who we become makes no one can take
that away from us so then once we arrive
at that level and we experience whatever
the dream is or whatever we create the
next thing is do it until you fully
enjoy it and then when it gets boring or
predictable let's go again let's do
something else think of your autonomic
nervous system as the automatic nervous
system and i've been saying for years
that autonomic is synonymous with
automatic and it's that
part of our
systems a part of our nervous system
that functions behind the scenes of our
awareness and it regulates body
temperature and and hormones and blood
supply and blood sugar levels
in it and it happens without any uh
of our conscious mind
so
in the autonomic nervous system there
are two branches so one is the
sympathetic nervous system and its job
is for
protection uh from threats and dangers
in our outer environment and think of
the sympathetic nervous system as the
gas pedal and when there's a danger to
the gross anatomy of the body
by something in our outer world that we
can perceive with our senses
this system is switched on automatically
and once it turns on
there's a host of physiological
functions
that begin to happen automatically
and when that occurs we're mobilizing
all of the body's energy
all of the body's resources
for that threat or that danger to deal
with it and and when it's switched on uh
we don't go half in we go all the way in
because we have to make sure that the
body is going to survive
survive in a threat or a danger in the
outer environment and and when there's a
release of all those adrenal hormones uh
we're tapping the body's resources
and we're mobilizing all of its energy
and pupils dilate salivary juices shut
off respiratory rate increases heart
rate increases
blood is sent to the extremities glucose
is mobilized the immune system dials up
and then it dials down and all of these
systems switching on and turning on is
to be able to allow the body to adapt to
some threat in the outer world and
that is the gas pedal and the
sympathetic nervous system or the
fight-or-flight nervous system
causes us to really do just a few things
to run
from the danger to fight
and stay
or to freeze and hide and those are the
primary choices that we have created in
evolution
and so
when the sympathetic nervous system is
switched on and we as we've been saying
for very long for a very long time
the short-term effect of the hormones of
stress the body can adapt and return
back to balance and it switches on
the other nervous system that branch of
the autonomic nervous system called the
parasympathetic nervous system
and think of that nervous system as the
break
or the clutch
this is where the body conserves energy
this is where utilizes nutrients and and
transports chemicals to cells and
metabolism goes up and and this is a
time for growth this is a time for
repair this is a time for restoration
and there's a delicate balance between
the sympathetic nervous system and the
parasympathetic nervous system
and so then when you're feeling
a constant fear
when you're feeling constant anger or
aggression when you're feeling constant
pain and suffering and you're living by
the hormones of stress
what was once very adaptive is now very
maladaptive because if stress is
knocking your brain and body out of
balance and the stress response is what
the body does to return it back to order
if we're living in constant fear then we
are tapping the body's vital resources
and there's no energy
for growth repair restoration there's no
energy for long-term building projects
so then when you're feeling gratitude
and your heart is open you're
broadcasting energy into the field now
frequency frequency you lay the intent
of the thought of your health or your
wealth
that frequency can carry the thought of
your wealth it can carry the thought of
your health if you're suffering
you can't the suffering does not carry
that energy does not carry the thought
of your wealth it carries a different
set of thoughts so then so then we're
teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future that
you're imagining with all of your heart
it better be open and activated and you
better know how to self-regulate and you
have to know
the moment you disconnect from the
energy of your future because of some
circumstance in your life and you lose
that feeling
if you're practicing it on a daily basis
with your eyes closed then the next
level is to be able to open your eyes
and do it right in the moment and be
able to self-regulate and change
the the frustration from some experience
in your life back to the energy of your
future now
that requires great awareness and great
effort but if you have a community of
people
that are practicing this on a daily
basis and they're connected to their
future because that's where their their
mind is
um they begin to want the future
more than the emotions of the past so
we've done enough measurements now lewis
to know that we can teach people how to
do that and we have evidence that people
can sustain it
for 45 minutes to an hour it's a skill
now they know that they know how to do
it so now they have brain coherence and
heart coherence well once the heart
begins to become orderly and coherent it
acts as an amplifier and it drives
energy to the brain so now the brain is
getting more energy once the heart is
open and then you're thinking different
set of thoughts and those thoughts
produce different chemicals for you to
feel more of that and here comes
uh nitric oxide from oxytocin and then
all of a sudden your heart literally
starts to swell it literally begins to
open up and there's more energy going
there and now you're coming from a
different level of mind crossing that
river of change from the old self to the
new self there's a neurological a
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self
but if you teach people there's
something on the other side they won't
give up on themselves they'll keep going
so there's enough evidence to encourage
people and you can't tell me you're too
old to do this work you can't tell me
you're too sick to do this work you
can't tell me you had a turbulent past
or or that you're too overweight or too
underweight or too out of shape or
you can't even tell me that you've never
meditated before in fact some of our
greatest scans or people who just have
never meditated before that are not
trying to do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible
and they go all in not 50 and not 60 and
we do a week-long event we got a
thousand people or 1500 people and they
are all in and that when they start
getting beyond themselves that first day
or second day once they start getting
beyond themselves and that magic starts
to happen then i have no idea i can't
predict
what's going to happen next and it's
usually pretty pretty exciting would you
speak about the neurophysiology
of forgiveness
sure
[Music]
think about
frozen circuits
frozen circuits
are hard wired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes
circuitry the more we think about the
experience the more we fire and wire the
circuits in our brain yes or no
and the more we remember the event the
more we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no yes and it you
keep doing it enough times it's no
longer conscious that you're holding a
grudge
it's no longer conscious
that
you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted
everybody
is that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality
you're not seeing it the way it is
you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception
triggers the emotion in the network and
you're back in your past and you're
acting like you were when it happened
are you with me still
and so then the person says i'm not that
person you say oh no i know i just had
this event in my past and i'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again and there's nothing wrong
with this
we all do it
it's just how do we overcome it
so then
you're sitting
and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers
you're releasing
the life force into your brain
you are
blessing those centers and taking a
scoop and moving it all the way up and
releasing it all the way up into the
field you're opening the channel
your unfolding is nobody no one no thing
nowhere in no time and the identity and
the personality is gone which energy's
going to move it's got to it's going to
follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care it's hard to hold a grudge
are you with me still yes
so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still
so then from a quantum perspective you
are actually
as a creator of reality
holding yourself hostage
because of that person
and you are holding them hostage because
of that experience
and you have an energetic bond that's
connecting you to them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that
energetic agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone
it's because there's been a strong
change
in your emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start
lowering the volume to that emotion and
the body starts liberating energy and
you're calling your energy back to you
because the lower the volume of the
emotion the less you're going to pay
attention to that person there comes a
moment where there's a snap
there's a release the energy is broken
and once it's broken now all of a sudden
you free yourself
and you free them
and
this has happened to me in my life
the people show up 10 years later
completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because
they had transformed and i let them go
so then
forgiveness
from a quantum perspective and a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them
that's all it is
and when you start getting happy with
yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for the
grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still now
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body the
bodies start getting a lift of energy
once it makes it's here now you're going
to see that track sending energy to the
brain the heart acts as an amplifier to
boost the brain
are you with me still
so then once the energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin and you
feel more loved then you feel the grudge
so then you think
why would i want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness
you don't have to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation
and oxytocin then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites
as fear and it lowers the volume to fear
and anxiety it shuts the lights out for
aggression and anger and hostility and
it cools the circuits off for suffering
and pain and the only thing you can feel
is a love for life
and that's when you're free now the
practice
of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it
takes a long time and a lot of work
and then you forgive and then you're
like i don't want to forgive him yeah
[Music]
halfway forgive him
and just never really authentic
forgiveness
do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and
she had severe
severe night terrors severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
she came to our event
in
in
tacoma washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
oneness
in the
and that frequency had a message for her
and it said
and she was an incredible bliss when
this happened
i sent four angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her terrors
that was the end
of her night she couldn't have a
relationship she couldn't she could not
live with anybody she was she was
isolated
one moment the divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy moved right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for
now she's healed she's healthy she's
happy and she's on with a new life she's
born again my mother would love this
she's born again in the same life
reborn in the same life didn't pass
through a birth canal for it she just
was born again
in the same life she got a new lease in
one instant
that energy was carrying a message
and it made its way all the way into the
body and the bliss and the joy and the
gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried what
made total sense to her
she's free one instant
to me that's true forgiveness most
people are waiting for their life the
change yes so they can feel gratitude to
feel abundance to feel whole you know
that's the old model of cause and effect
you know so if you're living with
emptiness you're living with lack you're
living with pain
most people have been conditioned that
something out there has to take away
this emptiness or feeling inside of them
but
if you believe that you're creating your
life
and you're living by lack well lack is
going to create abundance right so
so then it makes sense then that you
don't really actually
create wealth you generate wealth you
generate abundance so the moment you
start teaching your body emotionally
what that future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest well your body
is the unconscious mind believes it's
living in that future in the present
moment now it's the scientific fact that
it's the environment that signals the
gene okay
the end product from an experience in
the environment is an emotion
so when you begin to embrace an elevated
emotion you're beginning to signal the
gene ahead of the environment what's the
importance of that well genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and the function of
your body and the expression of proteins
is the expression of life so by you
creating an elevated emotion and
teaching your body what that future will
feel like before it's made manifest your
body's starting to live in that future
reality in the present moment now here's
the key
if you were able to become familiar with
gratitude become familiar with wholeness
become familiar with abundance to become
familiar with freedom and you're able to
generate those chemicals every single
day
more than likely you would be walking
around feeling like your future has
already happened then you would no
longer be looking for it to happen you
would already feel like it has happened
now what is the importance of that well
you're literally becoming somebody else
so you're leaving your lack you're
leaving your guilt you're leaving your
emptiness behind so your personality
literally is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life
your personal reality you got to change
your personality and here we go again
you got to start becoming conscious of
your unconscious thoughts you got to
start noticing how you act how you speak
you got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that
you begin to objectify your subjective
self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new choice a new choice should
lead to a new behavior a new behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there